good morning everybody and welcome to
SML
going to talk about today this
application that we built to detect our
flowers in high dimensional sensor data
and this work was done together with my
colleague Allah he was there before I
start I'd like to just tell quickly what
I'm going to talk about yeah so I'll
start by introducing you to what we do
here at SML then go and talk about the
particular product that I work on and
and then touch upon this application and
the algorithms that were involved in
building this particular application
okay so semiconductor chips are
basically all around us
they're only present you can find them
in your cameras smart phones televisions
smartwatches automobiles everything
right and for for these semiconductor
devices the transistors are the smallest
components on this semiconductor chip
and in fact they form the basic
functional building blocks for computing
and storage and for in a transistor
there are billions of these so you know
in a semiconductor device there are
billions of these transistors and the
semiconductor industry has been
continually driven by by striving for to
make these transistors smaller you're
after you and the reason is that the
smaller these transistors you are able
to make the more of these you can
squeeze in our unit area of your chip
and therefore you get more processing
power from these and as an additional
advantage what also happens is that your
chips become more energy efficient we
here at SML provide one of the key
technologies in involved in the
manufacturing of semiconductor chips
before I go on to talk about this key
technology I want to start with a short
video
so this is your iPhone probably not the
latest and as you look into this iPhone
you see this a8 chip a silicon wafer can
build thousands of these chips as you
start zooming in into this chip you see
an architecture that consists of layers
stacked all on top of each other as you
zoom in further you see that the first
few layers are the ones that define what
a transistor is and then layers on top
of that are the ones that are the
interconnects that provide power to
these transistors as you can imagine you
are talking about these transistors we
are very very tiny they are not even
visible to the naked eye and therefore
what is important here is that these all
these layers that are stacked on top of
each other need to be very well aligned
any misalignment here will cause
connection failures and cause the chip
to underperform overly is a parameter
that defines how miss line these layers
are and this is a critical parameter
that directly relates to the yield that
our customers can get from their
manufacturing process so we are at SML
need to strive to always have this
overlay which refers to the misalignment
between these layers within a very tight
budget okay so the key technology that I
was talking about is called photo
lithography and basically before I talk
about that it comes from the word
lithography which is derived from two
greek words
letha's which means stone and graphene
refers to writing so basically this was
the way of printing predating the modern
printing technology and what you have
here is that you have your lithography
stone which is prepared through a series
of step steps such that the ink that you
apply on it selectively sticks on the
graphic that is drawn on it and
therefore can be transferred as a mirror
image onto this paper when the paper is
placed and applied
some pressure on it and in fact your SML
we do something which is kind of similar
okay okay so yeah this is something that
is it's kind of similar to what we do
here at SML so to make an analogy the
light is like the ink and the graphic is
like the template the photo mask the one
that is shown here so when you have
light projected on this photo mask that
is shown in the picture on the right
this allows light to pass selectively
through it such that what is exposed on
the wafer is an inverse image on of what
the template is in the photo mask before
performing this step the wafer is coated
with a photosensitive material such that
only certain parts of the wafer where
light appears can change the chemical
properties and and then be degraded away
and through a series of steps that
involve like a deposition and etching
and alternating between these you can
actually create all these tiny features
that I just showed you and then you can
make these ships so overlay as I just
mentioned was one of the critical
parameters that is very great that is
that our customers need to worry about
and we are at SM Elle's make these
machines that enable photo lithography
these machines produce thousands of
wafers per day and being a mechanical
device the the machine is subjected to
drifts over time and if you are talking
about overlay which is measured in a few
nanometers so by the way a nanometer is
tendresse 2-9 of a meter so we are
talking about really small features and
to ensure that these features are kept
in tight control we need to measure and
then set up a feedback control loop to
control our scanners and for the
measurement this is the machine that we
also bail at ASML which is called the
heel start and I work on this and
through this measurement we are able to
control overlay for our customers
NuStar is an optical based tool that
provides very fast solution for wafer
metrology which is basically measuring
wafers and this uses the principle of
scatterometer ii to measure what is on a
wafer so the scatterometer scatterometer
ii refers to the fact that when you have
a beam of light incident on any
structure and as it reflects back then
it carries information about the very
structure as light interacts with it and
comes back and by looking at this
information and then combining it with
some machine learning models we are able
to provide a very fast solution to
measuring overlay on wafers and the
principle basically is that overlay
since it's a misalignment any
misalignment will show up in in the
symmetry of the beam that is also
reflected back and then you see it as a
signal that that measures overlay okay
so this is a schematic that shows the
yield star sensor and this is measuring
very close to this silicon wafer and
well as I told you we use machine
learning solutions to measure overlay on
papers and any kind of machine learning
solution requires good training data
what I mean by good training data is
that that if there are any outliers you
need to detect them and take them out
right so you know what you see is is the
performance of our machine learning
model when there were some outliers in
our training data what is shown here are
true values versus predicted values
right so for a good model the
correlation between these two should be
very high and what you see here is that
the correlation is not very high so the
model is not performing well you can
actually trace this back to certain
points in your data so what we are
measuring is on the way for every wafer
has certain fields and
kind of repeated in blocks over the
wafer and what I'm showing here is a one
particular field and in each of these
fields over the wafer what you find is
there are these three structures which
are different in sizes and because they
are different in their sizes they
produce a different signal and if you
just combine all these things together
you get a model that underperforms so
these you know in a sentence can be
interpreted as outliers for the data if
you were able to somehow identify these
structures and remove them from the
training data then you see that your
models are really improving you have a
much like larger R square and now the
question is well you could detect them
by for example looking at the wafer with
scanning electron microscope but that is
a very expensive process and it's not
fast enough the question is how can you
detect and filter out these outliers
directly from your from your data using
unsupervised methods and that's what I'm
going to talk about but before I go
there let's start by asking the question
what an outlier is one of the
definitions I like is that it is an
observation that deviates so much from
the rest of the observations that it
really starts arousing suspicions about
the fact that it might have been
possibility possibly generated from a
very different mechanism so to detect an
outlier what is important is a certain
distance contrast so let me explain what
you see here is an outlier and you can
clearly say so because it is very
different it is very far apart from the
rest of your data all right so the
distance contrast that I was referring
to is basically the following
so do denotes the distance from this
outlier point to the the in layer say
say and the I refers to the distance
within these in lies so the intra
cluster distances and if this is large
then you can clearly say that this is an
outlier on the other hand the image that
I show here it's not so clear that this
is an out
and the reason for this is that distance
contrast is low which comes from the
fact that well this point is not as
largely separated from the data and the
data also has more spread winner range
right so now in high dimensions if you
want to look at this distance contrast
things become kind of tricky and this is
related to a well-known phenomena which
is known as the curse of dimensionality
to explain that very quickly I have
let's say you have some eight points and
you try to put them in boxes of
different dimensions right all of them
have the same unit length and you see
two things here the first thing you see
is that well the data is more densely
packed in lower dimensions which is
obvious because you have more space to
fill the data in high dimensions the
second is that if you start looking at
the ratios of distances between these
points so let's say you focus on the
distance to the the first two points and
the distance between the endpoints if
you're looking at that ratio that is
very different in 1d compared to that
ratio in higher dimensions right so what
happens is that in high dimensions
almost all the distances become kind of
similar and therefore these distance
measures start losing their meaning and
this is referred to as the curse of
dimensionality so we suffer from this
problem because our signal is a very
high dimensional signal we have
thousands of pixels on our sensor and in
addition we have lot of noise which
would mean that things become very
tricky when you're trying to detect
outliers in relation to the distance
contrast that I was just talking about
so let us look at this in more detail so
if you'd like to try to write down this
ratio of these two distances because we
are talking about Euclidean distances
you just basically take the differences
in each dimension and then Square and
add them well one more thing I'd like to
add at this point is that because
although our signal is very high
dimensional what we are looking at is
ours
structures which which are not that
complex there are kind of simple
structures which means that the latent
representation of this data the
dimensionality of this latent space is
much smaller it's probably five or ten
it's not as high as as the number I've
shown there which means that there is of
course that that you can somehow think
of this data lying on a much lower
dimensional embedding and the nominal
distance is referred to the distances
without noise and if we talk about say
like white noise which is basically
additive in each dimension equally then
what you have in is in this ratio the
the the noise term that is dominating so
n capital n refers to the number of
dimensions and if small n refers to the
noise term and when you have large
dimensions and you have a noisy signal
then the second term starts domination
dominating and then what you have is
this contrast becoming close to one and
I well on the other hand if you were to
do a dimensionality reduction what you
would then see is that if there was an
outlier then you would be able to have a
much higher distance contrast so the
basic takeaway from the slide is that
when the dimensionality goes becomes
very large this distance contrast even
for points with outlier starts getting
closer to one and then therefore it
means it is difficult to detect outliers
and the solution is to look into
dimensionality reduction okay so well
about dimensionality reduction you can
think of two kinds of methods may be
linear and nonlinear methods like PCA
would clearly fail on on manifolds like
this which are kind of curved and
therefore you need to think of non
linear ones but a better way to think
about these dimensionality reduction
techniques is to think of once that
preserve global distances versus the
ones that preserve local distances right
so PCA is a method that tries to
basically preserve a variance in your
data and because variances is computed
by l2 norms
this is a method that really emphasizes
a global distance is more whereas
methods like TS knee or you map are once
that try to discover the embedding of
the data by looking more closely into
the local distance relationships
for example to discover this embedding a
naive way would be to start connecting
all the points that are within a certain
neighbor and then you can discover this
and well now if you want to detect
outliers then if you think of methods
that look into the first kind are they
would not be suitable because outliers
are once basically which which are which
are kind of extreme points and therefore
if you try to focus on distance on
methods that preserve more of group
global distances they would kind of bias
the very embedding that you are trying
to discover right so you should look
into the methods of the second time well
the method that we use here in our
application is it's called you map it
stands for uniform manifold
approximation and projection and while I
do not have the time to explain to you
how exactly it works
I would actually refer you to very
excellent talks by the author of this
method so allele in machines which are
available on YouTube where he explains
exactly how this works I'm only given to
be as give a very rough schematic so
let's say you have a representation of
your data in high dimensions denoted by
coordinates X I and you would like to
have the project then projected through
non linear methods into a low
dimensional representation with
coordinates Y I the way the problem is
solved is through an optimization
problem which tries to preserve the
distance structure in your data right
while methods like th knee and you map
all emphasize local distance this is
more than the global ones yet there is
always a trade-off to be made in
basically choosing what local exactly
refers to and that is done through this
parameter and n which refers to the
nearest neighbors which basically is a
parameter
that you have to use for your
application and a large values of this
nearest neighbors basically emphasize
more of the global differences in your
data while if n n is chosen to be small
then they emphasize more of the local
differences in your data
this is parameter that we have had to
kind of choose once for a kind for a
particular kinds of application and it
is kind of more or less robust but of
course if you have a very different
application you might need to retune
this well
once now once we have actually done
dimensionality reduction of your data
and have have it projected on a lower
dimensional space to detect outliers
what you would need to do is to run a
clustering on top right so if there were
outliers they would clearly show up in
this clustering about clustering what
was used here was an algorithm called as
htb scan which combines basically the
advantages of density and a hierarchical
based methods right so regarding density
based clustering methods the DB scan
algorithm is quite a popular one which
basically works on the principle that it
tries to identify a dense region in your
data and to define what dense is it
requires two parameters epsilon and
midpoints so the way it works is
basically around each point in your data
you create a spherical ball with a
certain radius epsilon and if the number
of points the number of neighbors that
this radius encloses is greater than
main points you call the point to be
dense and then you basically start
connecting all the dense points that are
kind of nearest neighbors of each other
and that defines
what a dense region is and you associate
that with a cluster now the difficulty
here is that you require to make a
choice of epsilon which is not so clear
for for application that is kind of
unknown to you and more importantly you
require to choose a fixed value of
Epsilon right so basically what you see
here you have data with two different
densities right so this was generated by
from three clusters so you have these
two clusters with more or less the same
density and you are the third cluster
which is spread out and what you find is
that like a single value of epsilon will
never work on this kind of data and the
reason is if you choose epsilon to be
large enough then you can detect these
two clusters right so the one on the
left and it merges the other two small
ones if you make this small to separate
out these two smaller clusters what you
find is that the bigger cluster is
registered as noise because those data
points are not found to be dense enough
so as DB scan tries to correct this by
having only a single parameter and the
identification of clusters is done by
finding an adaptive epsilon depending on
the on which region of the data are you
looking for so what you see here is this
you can it automatically discovers that
there are three clusters and and then is
able to label them correctly okay so
coming back to the slide that I showed
you before we have this high dimensional
data from our sensors that basically
looks at overlay or misalignment between
two layers
on the wafer and this high dimensional
data is is basically projected on a
three dimensional space using Yuma and
what you see here is a representation of
that if you now start correlating the
locations on wafer for all these all
these dimensionality reduce data what
you find is a clear structure so you
find basically all the orange points
being clearly associated with the
inliers
and you find three other clusters each
corresponding to these three locations
on every field of the wafer so it tells
you automatically that there are three
kinds of outliers which are distinct
from the other points and once you once
you know this you can filter them out
and as I just explained before you have
training data which is cleaner and you
have better performance from your
machine learning model what is important
typically at SML is to have good
interpretability of your results so here
in fact this was confirmed by experts by
looking at scanning electron microscope
images that these were indeed very
different structures that you are trying
to measure and and they indeed show of
course differently in the U map and
bearing so at this point I'd like to
conclude and show you a summary of what
I just talked about so the first point
is that to look at to have robust
machine learning solutions you need to
filter outliers from the training data
because the presence of outliers can
cause your model to be biased in an
unwanted way if you are looking at very
high dimensional data then it's a good
idea to look at dimensionality reduction
and then followed up with clustering so
that you can visualize these outliers
and then can filter them out and once
you have done so then you have much
better performance from your model and
in the end Python libraries can be used
to actually solve real-world industry
problems and I'd like to say that we use
a you map
HDB scan in particular here which are
both available as open source Python
libraries thank you
[Applause]